en el vídeo anterior nos quedamos
realizando el volumen de este cubo y
usamos una integral triple para calcular
este volumen y yo sé que probablemente
estaban pensando bueno para que hacer
todo esto si podemos simplemente
multiplicar lo alto por lo ancho por lo
profundo y tienen razón nuestra función
era un valor constante e incluso cuando
hicimos la integración y evaluamos con
respecto a z terminamos con una integral
doble de la misma manera que lo
hubiéramos hecho en los vídeos pasados
pero al final del vídeo agregamos algo
diferente qué tal si nuestra meta no
hubiera sido calcular el volumen sino
encontrar la masa de este volumen y aún
más esta masa no iba a estar distribuida
de manera homogénea en esta en este
volumen de manera que su densidad no es
constante así que ahora la masa se
vuelve algo así como interesante de
calcular
así que nosotros definimos una función
de ansiedad
esta rom o esto que parece una p que nos
da la densidad en un punto específico
al final del vídeo anterior nos quedamos
en la pregunta de qué es masa
la masa es la densidad por el volumen o
pueden decir que la densidad es lo mismo
que la masa dividida entre volumen así
que la masa alrededor de un punto muy
muy muy pequeño que llamamos de masa o
la diferencial de la masa va a ser igual
a la densidad en ese punto la densidad
aproximada en ese punto x la diferencial
del volumen en ese punto multiplicado
por el volumen de este cubo pequeñito y
como lo vimos en el vídeo anterior
estamos usando coordenadas rectangulares
esta diferencia en el volumen se puede
definir como la distancia en x por la
distancia por la distancia está así que
qué tal si nosotros quisiéramos conocer
cuál es la densidad definida en x jay-z
y queremos calcular la masa de este
volumen
digamos que nuestras coordenadas x están
en metros y esta necesidad está en
kilogramos por metro cúbico así que
nuestra respuesta va a estar en función
de kilogramos que es la unidad común
para masa
vamos a calcular la masa en este volumen
de densidad variable para esto tenemos
esta misma integral de aquí
le escribimos aquí abajo
así que la diferencial de la masa vamos
a escribirlo
y déjenme asegurarme de que no nos vamos
a quedar sin espacio
x zeta
multiplicado
y ahora te voy a integrar con respecto
de z primero pero ustedes podrían
comenzar en cualquier otro orden para
hacer la integral y quizás lo hagamos
así en el siguiente vídeo hacemos de z
primero luego de y
y finalmente de equis y bueno de nuevo
esto es solamente la masa era una
pequeña diferencial de volumen y se
integramos con respecto a z primero
y recordemos que se trabaja de dónde a
dónde los límites de seta va de 0 a 20 a
los límites en que recordamos que van de
0 a 4 y los límites con respecto a x van
de 0 atrás y bueno como vamos a evaluar
esto cuál es la andi derivada de esta
parte con respecto a z
y esta parte que estoy subrayando aquí
con respecto a z así que nos queda x y z
al cuadrado entre 2
es lo evaluamos de 0 a 2
esto no esté quedando sin espacio
a tener 2 al cuadrado
qué es 4 dividido entre 2 nos va a
quedar 2x
- ser así que la evaluación de esto es
este elemento nada más
nos quedan además otras dos integrales
las integrales con respecto a jane y con
respecto al x
recordamos que lleva de 0 a 4 y x va de
0 atrás y definitivamente me estoy
quedando sin espacio aquí ahora es el
anti derivada de esto con respecto a iu
y esto es la anti derivada con respecto
a lleva a ser igual donde lo escribo
para que el espacio
una vez por acá
voy a tener que borrar esta parte porque
no puedo recorrer me más
ok todo esto
vamos a continuar entonces la anti
derivada con respecto ayer de esto lo
voy a escribir aquí
y me va a quedar
esto es constante está encuadrada así
que nos queda x por cuadrada evaluado de
0 a 4 y tenemos la integral exterior de
0 a 3
con respecto a x evaluamos esto
10 44 al cuadrado es 16
16 x aquí esto es 0 todo lo demás es 0 y
eso lo integramos de 0 atrás y esto va a
ser igual a
8 x x al cuadrado evaluado de 0 3
al cuadrado es 9 por 8 72 el otro 0 esto
se cancela así que nada más nos queda
con 72 recuerden que el volumen que
encontramos la vez pasada era 24 metros
cúbicos pero su masa es de 72 kilogramos
y esto lo encontramos al integrar esta
función de ansiedad con tres variables o
lo pueden interpretar como en tres
dimensiones en donde se encuentra un
valor de densidad en cualquier punto
integramos este campo escalar en este
volumen y esto señoras y señores es una
nueva habilidad que acabamos de aprender
en el siguiente vídeo les mostraré cómo
desarrollar integrales triples un poco
más complicadas pero realmente la
dificultad de las integrales triples y
creo que ustedes lo han visto es que a
menos de que tengan una figura muy
sencilla cómo está la evaluación si
quieren resolver analíticamente esta
evaluación esta integral triple que
tenga límites más complicados como por
ejemplo que la función densidad sea más
difícil las integrales se van a poner
mucho más densas y mucho más rápido de
manera que consume mucho tiempo está
resolviendo esto por eso verán que
cuando tienen exámenes en donde empiezan
a ser integrales triples dan por hecho
que ustedes ya han hecho integrales de
este tipo y anti derivadas
y a veces cuando quieren darles algo más
complicado les cambian el orden
les dicen que en lugar de hacer integral
con respecto a z x
lo re escriben o reescribe en esta
integral para cambiar el orden y esto lo
veremos pronto así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo